Donald Trump got on Twitter wanted to
tweet about China capturing an American
drone he ended up channeling none other
than Sarah Palin making up the word this
is just so good unprecedented now you
might say David you're pronouncing that
wrong no I'm not I'm not saying the word
unprecedented i'm not saying without
precedent i'm saying on presidenta de
which means without a president let's
look at the tweet which Donald Trump has
since taken down China steals United
States Navy research drone in
international waters rips it out of
water and takes it to China in on
presidenta de act Donald Trump thought
that the word unprecedented without
precedent was unprecedented like without
a president Trump's message was itself
an unprecedented action president elects
usually wait until after they're knotted
to start talking about sensitive
diplomatic matters if at all
particularly on Twitter this is the new
word pad under Donald Trump the United
States will be unprecedented yeah it's
pretty fantastic I mean at this point
how is no one taking away his Twitter
account I could kind of see it when he
was just running for president I agree
he has a whole team behind him how is
this not getting monitored which also
crazy as it took 90 minutes for this
tweet to be deleted and then REE REE
published with the correct word
unprecedented I'm gonna be regularly
using this word unprecedented the entire
trump presidency is going to uh uh but
show us any number of unprecedented act
and again Trump tweeting sort of at odd
times this one 630 am I guess is less
odd than three a.m. but there's a real a
simple explanation Pat for the strange
timing of the tweets Trump is keeping
Russian Standard Time so when he tweets
at 3am in New York it's 11am in Moscow
which is sort of a normal time for
tweeting that's what's going on I see
that you've solved the puzzle here but
Trump's lack of being presidential is
really going to set precedent for future
presidents through countless
unprecedented actions that will make me
feel like the u.s. truly is
unprecedented it's also odd again that
it took nearly 90 minutes for the Trump
team to correct this on Twitter can we
expect
same level of sort of uh what what what
I don't even know what to call it uh
just fumbling about in the dark once
Trump is president I mean are we to
expect tweets with made-up words once he
is actually in the Oval Office it's
scary you have to wonder that his
actions will be a little bit more
calculated right but he claims to have
the best words yeah and not only that oh
do we have that video I think i mighta
skipped over yet did I skip I did skip
over this in my in my haste to continue
talking about unprecedented
unprecedented acts I forgot about Donald
Trump's own statement that he's really
good with words I went to an Ivy League
school I'm very highly educated I no
words at the best word to da clearly one
of those Brett best words is
unprecedented I almost skipped over yeah
you have to include that one that that's
a must include so okay Donald Trump a
bead it's like this is Palin s this is
Palin asked and we figured out that
Trump at some point determined it wasn't
a good idea to have Sarah Palin involved
with his campaign or with his cabin or
as an advisor she showed up after
endorsing Trump and gave this bizarre
word salad speech Trump looked scared
standing behind her it was there's a
futile attempt to use the English
language to communicate anything with
meaning and after that she was basically
completely removed from any public
facing Trump thing yes they're Palin's
not going to be in his cabinet she's
sure is going to show up in his
vocabulary yeah that that that we are
absolutely seeing discuss this story
with us or any other stories from
today's show or any other story you
would like us to cover on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash read it that's our EDD IT and
remember we are raising money to make a
big expansion of the david pakman show
and our progressive activism reach check
it out at david pakman.com slash donate
we will be back right after this the
holiday season starts this week and
there is not much time left to shop and
I suggest avoiding long lines mall
parking lots and all of that insanity
you can actually get a gift from shari's
berries which is a sponsor of today's
show you can skip all of the nonsense
hands and just schedule the gift to be
delivered on the day that you want it to
show up you can choose berries dipped in
tempting white milk and dark chocolaty
goodness topped with chocolate chips
decorative swizzle or chopped nuts these
are unique gifts which I guess the
people you give them two could share
with others if they want to do we
actually got a sharis berries box here
in the studio and we put some of them
out in the common area and within about
10 minutes people had just come out of
the woodwork on our floor and had tried
them and everybody seemed to absolutely
love it of course you can get a great
discount and support the david pakman
show with the amazing 1999 shari's
berries deal if you go to Barry's com
that's berr IES com click on the
microphone in the top right-hand corner
of the page and type in my code Pakman
that's PA que ma n you go to Barry's com
click on the microphone and type in
Pakman to get the 1999 deal today